[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen meine tagen
welt heute bekommt hier ein weiteres
rezept von mir und zwar mein country
rezept ich sehe es jetzt mal nicht so
den plättchen mit dazu das gibt es
nämlich bei uns das ganze jahr über das
ist ein italienisches gepäck und ich
zeige euch jetzt einmal die zutaten
benötigt 250 gramm mehl 200 gramm
mandeln 100 gramm zucker eine prise salz
und zwei esslöffel vanille zucker einen
teelöffel backpulver zweier 25 gramm
butter und ein halbes fläschchen
bittermandel aroma
das waren 11 den grundzutaten und ihr
könnt den teig noch verfeinern mit
zitronenschale und ihr müsst auf jeden
fall noch eine flüssigkeit mitte zu
geben etwa 30 bis 40 millimeter und da
könnt ihr dann entweder kaffee mit
anzugeben oder amaretto oder
irgendwelche anderen legalen oder aromen
ich werde zwar etwas an entweder zu
geben und dann noch zitronenschale
gebt dann alle zutaten ihr eure schüsse
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt die mandeln mitte zog
lasse ich den teig erst mal durchführen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
normalerweise benutze ich immer
gestiftete und ganze mandeln heute habe
ich aber keine gestiftete deswegen habe
ich meine mandeln jetzt noch zur hälfte
in stifte und ihr dürft euch nicht
verwundern der club- der teig da ist
ziemlich klebrig aber der gehört so ihr
könnt auch nur ganze mandeln benutzen
aber ich finde es irgendwie besser wenn
auch ein paar gehackte mandeln mit 30
[Musik]
dann geb dir die mantel hier einfach
auch die charakter und die verknetet ihr
das könnt ihr auch mit der maschine
machen lassen
[Applaus]
den teig dann werde ich hart trainiert
weiter bearbeiten da muss nicht mehr
gekühlt werden und die karte chinesen
eigentlich schon fast fertig also die
zubereitung geht wirklich einfach und
das wollen wir noch ganz wenige schritte
dann gebt ihr etwas nele auf die
arbeitsfläche oder etwas mehr datei
klebt nämlich ziemlich und kratzt diesen
klebrigen teil aus der form heraus
[Applaus]
achtet jetzt immer gut drauf dass ihr
genug mehl zwischen teig und euren
händen habt sonst klebt der wirklich
sehr stark angewendet
den teig halbiert ihr jetzt in zwei
teile und die teilt ihr dann noch mal in
drei gleich große stücke
und jedes dieser kugel formt ihr jetzt
zu einer rolle
und jede rolle hat ungefähr 25 cm in der
länge
und achtet beim rollen darauf dass die
rolle in der dicke recht regelmäßig
verläuft
[Musik]
die rolle gibt ihr dann auf eure
vorbereitetes backblech und damit die
jetzt darauf achten genügend platz
zwischen den rollen zu lassen
und letzten vier auf ein mich das passt
dann ganz gut wenn man die doppelte
menge packt dann hat man drei blätter
von mach ich's nämlich meistens die
rollen die man jetzt bei etwa 190 grad
11 bis 34 minuten vorgebacken wenig sie
aus dem oben genommen hast 10 die
stangen etwas so aus die müssen jetzt
noch entscheiden geschnitten werden und
das machen b kurz nehmt euch dazu eine
schlange und schneidet sie aber etwas
diagonal das sieht später besser aus und
dann etwa ein zentimeter
[Musik]
danach nimmt ihr euch die scheibchen und
gibt sie auf ein backblech
da braucht ihr auch kein papier dafür
die kleben hier nicht mehr und ordnet
sie aber mit der schnittkante nach oben
an
damit sie schön an der schnittkante doch
osten
[Musik]
die community eine zweite gebacken weil
das selben temperatur als 190 grad für
etwa zehn bis zwölf minuten da müsst ihr
einfach schauen dass die farbe bekommen
aber nicht zu dunkel werden aber auch
eine schöne röstung haben die kantone
sind fertig wenn sie ungefähr so eine
freude angenommen haben
wenn die kekse abkühlen sind bewahrte
sie am besten in so einer dose auf und
starten sie eigentlich auch längere zeit
haltbar
[Musik]
wie es ist ziemlich einfach cappuccinos
herzustellen und ich finde wer wusste
schon macht und sich den aufwand macht
kann man auch gleich eine doppelte menge
machen und jetzt wünschen viel spaß beim
nachbacken und gebt mir einfach feedback
zu diesem video und zudem rezept und
schon sehen wir uns einfach das nächste
mal wieder biss dann tschüss
[Musik]